Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
A lot of you been asking me to do a video
about the Harry Potter reboot trailer.
They just dropped an announcement
about how they're going to plot out
this full reboot series that they're doing
All explain what's going on
and what it means for the new Harry Potter
movies that they also talked about. J.K.
Rowling also said they're continuing
to do more Harry Potter movies, but
said in different parts of the timeline,
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
They only just started working on it,
but they're going full steam ahead.
And I will do episode videos
when it releases.
They've been working on this
for a long time, trying to lock J.K.
Rowling down to a deal like they had
to get her to sign on the dotted line.
And the important thing is, first,
this is meant to be a full on
reboot of the original Harry Potter books,
which is a bit of a surprise.
Like, we knew they were doing a Harry
Potter series.
We were just kind of wondering
what it would actually be about.
But the rebooting, the events of Harry,
hermione, Ron,
all the main characters story that we read
during those original books,
and they already greenlit the full series
for order,
which is way beyond what you normally get.
This means they ordered beyond
just the first episode, like there's
no pilot episode or just the first season,
pretty much the entirety of all
the original books have been greenlit
two episodes in as part of the deal
that it took to get a Harry Potter series
about the mainline characters again,
they had to approve a ten year run for
the series, meaning at least ten seasons.
They didn't say exactly how many episodes
per season, but it would be about what
House of the Dragon Game of Thrones were,
meaning 8 to 10 episodes per season,
every single fan of the books.
And there are millions,
many millions of us now asking,
There aren't ten books,
there are only seven books.
Why are there ten seasons for seven books?
This is because part of J.K.
Rowling's deal with Warner Brothers
and HBO to get the series actually going
to actually signed
the deal was that they would cover
every single thing in all the books
without cutting out any plot,
which is what happened
with the original Harry Potter movies.
It's actually happening
with Game of Thrones
and House of the Dragon right
now, too, to talk about George R.R.
Martin, another major
author who's getting a lot of stuff
cut out of his books
to cram it into seasons
is basically what happened
with the original Harry Potter movies.
If you only watched the original movies
with Daniel Radcliffe, Emma
Watson and Rupert Grint,
even though they split the events
of the last book into two movies,
they did eight movies for seven books.
They still went up
cutting a massive amount of stuff
out of each book to cram the events
of each one into a single movie,
with the exception of Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows.
And even then, with two full movies
in about four and a half hours to do
that one book, they still had to cut out
a lot of stuff from Deathly Hallows.
So the ten Seasons allows them to go
full Deathly Hallows for all the books
when they need to break the events
of some of the larger books
in the multiple seasons.
And it also means
they can start working on season two,
Season three, so on much, much sooner
so that there aren't massive breaks
between the seasons, which is what
just happened with House of the Dragon.
HBO waited
until like the last possible minute
after House of the Dragon Season
one had released,
had been proven
a hit like everyone loved it.
So that great will do all the seasons now.
But that means that they couldn't start
working on season two till way, way later.
And that's why we had to wait two years
for House of the Dragon Season two.
And they don't want that to happen with
something like Harry Potter,
which they know is going to be crazy
popular.
Zooming in hands on the book chart here,
the first two books
are the shortest by far,
so they can probably cover
the events of Sorcerer's
Stone and Chamber of Secrets
completely in season one.
In season two,
Prisoner of Azkaban is pretty close.
They could probably cover that
in a single season three.
But you notice, starting with Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire,
the length of each book more than doubles,
which is where they need to start
using two seasons
to cover the events of each book.
They might try to cram Goblet of Fire
into a single season four
or just give it a slightly longer
episode run.
But the order of the Phenix would probably
be season five and season six.
Half-Blood Prince would probably be season
seven and season eight,
and then obviously Deathly Hallows
would be season nine and season ten.
That could wind up changing a little like
they could always wind up doing 11 seasons
and use two seasons for Goblet of Fire.
But this is just the beginning.
They only have a loose plan
for how long they'll spend on each season.
Like, remember,
we're talking ten years into the future
now, a lot of can change in ten years.
The original actors Daniel Radcliffe, Emma
Watson, Rupert Grint,
as well as the other actors,
have talked about how they feel about them
doing a reboot in the past.
Most of them, like Daniel Radcliffe
and Emma Watson, have said they never plan
on coming back as the characters
in new movies later in the timeline.
But both of them have said, Oh,
we do know they'll eventually reboot.
The movies are just a reality,
like it doesn't bother us that much.
So yeah, it was it was very
it was a very good ten years,
so they don't care
quite as much about them
actually rebooting their characters.
Rupert Grint, though, was like
one of the three mains who was like,
Oh yeah, totally.
I would love to come back
and do an older version of Ron,
but it doesn't
really make sense to do that
unless you also get the older
Daniel Radcliffe to do older
Harry Potter and hermione to come back.
Before all this happened,
a lot of us had way tamer theories
about their Harry Potter series plans.
Most of us had assumed that they would do
a series set during a different part
of the timeline, like a marauder series,
because they could still feature
most of the major characters
from the main series,
like Voldemort, Dumbledore,
just as younger
versions of the characters.
That's kind of what they did
with the Fantastic Beasts movie.
Like they kind of slowly
turned into Dumbledore movies,
even though they didn't start out
that way.
A lot of us also thought
that they might do a Severus Snape series
or a young Voldemort series,
or they go way back in the timeline
and do a founder series about the four
founders of Hogwarts, Godric Gryffindor,
Helga Hufflepuff, Rowena
Ravenclaw and Salazar Slytherin.
One of the important details, though,
is that J.K.
Rowling will not be writing
all the episodes herself.
They'll actually have teams
of experienced showrunners
and show writers
actually working on the series,
and she'll just get approval on scripts,
which is kind of how the situation
with the original Harry Potter
movie writing went,
where she didn't do the bulk
of the writing of the movies herself.
She just approved a lot of their scripts.
When they got to the fantastic Beast
movie, though,
they actually did let her write
most of those movies, which is why
the movies felt a little bit weaker
because she's amazing at writing novels
that the original Harry
Potter books are amazing books,
but she's not a great screenwriter.
So I'm glad that they're going back
to the old method of writing the episodes
for the series.
I think that'll just ultimately lead
towards better quality actual episodes.
But according to J.K.
Rowling,
they are still making new Harry Potter
movies, and all of our theories
have now been flipped.
And now the new movies
are going to be telling stories
that are jumping around in the timeline.
J.K. Rowling was kind of noncommittal
when asked about which events
the next movies would cover.
Warner Brothers
already said that they don't have any more
fantastic Beasts movies in development.
That franchise is basically dead
with the last fantastic Beasts movie,
and it sounds like they'll do Marauders
movies, a founder series of movies, events
like that, or they go full Star Wars
and try to do events much later
in the timeline, much longer after
the main characters have passed away.
House of the Dragon is doing this
for Game of Thrones right now.
But just as HBO series
like their only series,
they haven't announced Game of Thrones
movies or anything like that.
Just jumping around in the timeline.
I just did another video
for that Game of Thrones,
A Night of the Seven Kingdoms trailer,
which they also released
when they released this Harry Potter
reboot trailer,
like there
were a bunch of different series
they all announced at the same time
with trailers.
They did just bring back the entire
Harry Potter cast from the movies
for a reunion special on HBO.
Max a little while ago,
but that was more of a glorified behind
the scenes featurette, kind of like
the cast of a Friends reunion.
They didn't come back to do a new movie
or a new episode.
They just sat around and talked
about the movies,
like a longer version
of a Blu ray DVD special feature
because they just announced
the full series have been greenlit.
It's going to be at least 2025 before
they can start getting episodes out.
They haven't announced
any kind of casting yet
who's
going to be playing all the characters,
but there could be
some of the original movie
actors returning in different roles
because they're obviously much older now.
They'd have to be playing
different characters.
Dan You recently gave an interview
on a podcast where you said
if you ever went back to Harry Potter,
you would play another character
like Sirius Black or something.
How long after the podcast went live, did
a producer call you to see if you were?
Sarah
If you're a fan of the DC series they did,
This was stuff like the Flash series
in Modern Day, where they had
John Wesley Shipp from the Nineties
Flash series come back as Barry's father,
so they could bring back
some of the original actors
just playing
slightly different characters.
But the thing is,
obviously it hasn't been that long.
That's why a lot of fans got upset
because it's literally
like right after they finished the movies,
it hasn't been that long.
Usually when they reboot movies
and Warner Brothers did just announce
that they're rebooting the original Lord
of the Rings movies with new movies,
usually they wait more than 20 years
before trying to reboot things like,
We're not talking about Spider-Man
here, it's Sony.
That's the best example of them
rebooting stuff right away with them
rebooting from Tobey Maguire
into Andrew Garfield.
And then very quickly, soon after into the
Tom Holland version of Spider-Man,
everybody's now hoping for Harry Potter
into the Potter verse
where
like all the different characters come
and they just say that they're
all happened in different universes
where, like Daniel Radcliffe comes back
with whatever new version of Harry Potter
they wind up casting.
The funny thing about that is that Daniel
Radcliffe is like a hardcore
Star Wars fan.
A lot of these other franchises.
So it would be funny to see him pop up
in like a marvel movie or Star Wars movie.
One of the reasons
why you don't see that happening, though,
Emma Watson, too, is because they made
so much money on Harry Potter.
They're so iconic as those characters.
They don't feel like they need to do
movies just for the paycheck.
Like you would get giant paychecks
for these big comic
book movies or big Star Wars movies.
So just enables them to be
a little more selective with their roles
and just do weirder stuff because
they already have giant piles of money,
which is how you get Daniel
Radcliffe playing a farting corpse in.
The funny thing about that movie,
big coincidence here is that the directors
of that Farting Corpse Daniel
Radcliffe movie are actually the directors
who made everything everywhere
all at once, which was fantastic.
Everybody let me know in the comments
though, like, what do you want them to do
for this new ten year
long plus Harry Potter series?
Who do you want them to cast for actors?
It's still a little bit early to start
talking about who they're going to cast,
but obviously they'll be much younger
versions of the characters.
And as for the Lord of the Rings
reboot movies,
they haven't released
any kind of teaser trailer for that yet,
so it sounds like it's going to be much
longer before those start releasing.
Elijah Wood also kind of did the same
thing, like the Daniel Radcliffe thing
where you're asked about how you feel
about the reboot, like the Rebooting
The Lord of the Rings movies.
What do you think about this?
He was actually pretty nice about it.
Like, Oh, you know,
I knew they would reboot them eventually.
I hope they do a good job.
Hope this isn't a big cash grab,
so with any luck they'll actually spend
the time that they need to to make this
Harry Potter series actually be good.
Otherwise,
that next ten years would be a slog.
But like I said, because they just started
they're going to be writing scripts now,
starting actual work on the series.
It'll take them a couple of years
before you actually get episodes.
So would actually be a good long while
before
we actually get the next real trailer.
I'll probably wait till we start
getting really big announcements
or like really big trailers
before I start doing some more videos
to leave
all your requests in the comments below.
If you have any special questions
about what's going on with this
Harry Potter reboot or any of the other
big reboots that are happening,
I just did a trailer video
for Game of Thrones
Night of the Seven Kingdoms,
so I'll put a link for that
at the end of this
and down to the description below.
You can click here to watch that
and click here for My Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 8 Finale Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.